what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
on freshman fit and i am going to be
vlogging my experience so
first of all i'm gonna show you guys my
outfit took me like 20 years to pick out
because i'm very indecisive and if
you're live right now right there you
are going to see like all the different
outfits i went through which is a
million this is what we got going
it's a little mommy but that's kind of
my style is like mom
material
all right guys so i'm packed up i'll
show you i just packed up my
my bag cars pack
i'm ready to go to miami
it's gonna it's gonna be a fun night
so i'm gonna keep you guys posted
okay guys so i'm in miami i'm at a
stoplight now but
okay
i think i did not get a hotel in a very
nice area i'm cheap
so i'm gonna be honest did i pick the
cheapest one
yeah i did
it is what it it is what it is it's who
i am as a person
you know take it or leave it i don't
like to spend money like that um okay
second off second off
i'm getting a little nervous turn left
onto westflex i've been thinking
oh my gosh is there a starbucks oh my
god i gotta go get it
all right guys
i just checked into the hotel i got my
room whatever i put my parking pass in
the car
but
look at we got
this is the hotel
and
i'm going to show you my live like
reactions
um
okay
we got
okay i have
a very irrational
fear
i have a very irrational fear of getting
like killed
in hotel rooms so i like
oh god okay i'm gonna show you guys the
room it's very basic
again i'm cheap i don't like spending
money this is what we got it's like good
enough honestly
i just need a bed
bathroom
um
but yeah this is where i'm staying look
at that fine ass
i'm kid i kid
but
best feeling after a long drive but i'm
excited i think this is gonna be fun i
have it's like 8 8 30 so i have like
a little bit of time i'm gonna see how
far i am from fresh and fit
sorry back to what i was saying okay
i'm nervous because i just get nervous
before like big things
i don't know like i know they have a lot
of people watching right now but i'm
torn because
it's not really my drama so
i don't know if i should even bring up
the abba and preach stuff because it's
not it's not my drama so like why would
i
but it'll be interesting like i wonder
if they're gonna talk about that tonight
um
but yeah miami
pretty cool so far pretty cool
okay guys i got my starbees um i'm doing
this
actually i'm trying to quit coffee but
the problem is that i'm it might be up
so late like they do their show at 10
p.m i'm old
okay so i think i'm here but i'm like
slightly early
so i'm just like chilling outside for a
hot minute but this is like the
indoor place
oh my god i'm nervous i
i get so nervous
okay guys i've made it to the lobby at
fresh and fit this place is like way
cooler than anywhere
i've ever lived honestly
well maybe my parents house is pretty
cool i made a friend
hi sunny this is her first time on the
show too so are you how are you feeling
good yeah
i'm nervous random questions like kind
of make me nervous yeah i mean it's like
if they're saying something like i don't
know what it is i'm gonna be like
oh my god i have no idea
yeah i know me too okay oh god oh god i
got that on camera
oh my god i just hit my head guys
okay but we're about to go up like
fairly soon so
i don't know i'm excited
okay guys i made it here
they have you take off your shoes when
you get in
it's like
and then over here
it's like drinks and stuff
oh my god this equipment is so nice
i'm so jealous
people were asking what like the behind
the scenes looks like
and it's kind of cool they have like
literally the nicest equipment
oh god
and this is like the
other behind
this is the view from like where we're
sitting here
yeah okay guys
this is my friend noel she's this is her
third time on the podcast what what do i
have to expect coming out today lots of
opinions okay some arguing might happen
some frank castling as they said what is
that when they kicked him out
have you been kicked out no i'm very
late
okay even if i don't agree with stuff i
just decided okay some people want to
argue
what was your biggest disagreement last
time
on them wanting multiple women
well it's funny because like the high
value man they talk about that's my dad
like so it's like there'd be like oh he
has multiple men i'm like my dad my
dad was super faithful to my
okay guys this is my other friend i made
this is zarya
what are you most excited for today um
i'm most excited to just be engaged in
this conversation whatever conversation
that we've been engaging
and i'm just really just all
i was about to ask if it was your first
time
is there any topic that like you're
ready to talk about that you've heard on
the podcast you just want to be cheating
oh okay do you think it's okay or no
you know what
i i don't but i will get there
i'll have a lot of feelings about the
interviews
and
there's like a
balcony here which is kind of cool it's
like literally like
the
view of the whole city
here with the lakes are you excited yes
they are a little bit nervous but you
know they came early on time you know
we out here
are you ladies uh ready to go in a bit
definitely we out here
okay guys i made another friend
hey guys um so you
have not been here before it's your
first time
no
maybe
i mean i've been here but i mean it's
sasha if you're talking about sasha or
teresa they might have been here okay
tell me what was your biggest agreement
and disagreement last time
just the way how
women think a little bit is agreeing or
disagreeing with mind if i think video
with you
i'm afraid
wait who's on here no one is just oh
this is the video okay so i mean just as
far as like the mental process
of how they think
men want yeah
yeah they think you think they they got
that right or wrong wrong oh wrong wrong
wrong but then again there's like two
there's different calibers of men yeah
so are you talking about like the like
age weight type stuff like no no no no
no talking about
mindsets like the mindsets that men like
of women or don't like
so basically
i feel like there are two different
calibers of mindsets with men like
so there's some women they know how to
attract a certain caliber of man and
then there's other women who not to
attract another caliber of men okay and
then
then there's just in between where
people just they don't have any clue so
they're doing things that they should be
doing with the
lower caliber and they're trying that
with higher and it's not working because
what the higher caliber wants the lower
caliber doesn't work
it's okay are you excited to go on
yeah
yeah
it is good exposure
okay they bring up some pretty good like
they bring up some pretty good topics
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
guys i'm so mad i forgot i was gonna get
a video and a picture with myron and
fresh after
but i completely forgot like i literally
just slipped my mind but
it was so fun i had a blast um
i think i came prepared
um i think some points like they
were a little bit more prepared on but i
i i definitely
some
points i i did good i'm happy with the
performance
um
yeah i would go back
and for everyone that keeps talking
about like the ebb and preach stuff guys
that shit's got nothing to do with me
i'm just chilling anyways
bye